[Música]
tomamos decisões o tempo todo que mais
fazemos na vida e tomar decisões e
decisões de todos os tipos decisões
simples como que roupa vestir para vir
aqui que comer e decisões complexas onde
investir o dinheiro o que comprar o
imóvel uma bicicleta casar
o tempo todo a gente está às voltas com
decisões mas a pergunta que eu faço pra
vocês é durante a sua tomada de decisão
ou parte do seu cérebro você escuta mais
quem tem mais voz para tomar decisões
por exemplo eu estou fazendo dieta e
chego diante de uma mesa suculenta com
doces com massas
quem está tomando a decisão quem tomar a
rédea agora você come mesmo de dieta
eu como muitas vezes um relatório ou a
série que você adora que acabou de
lançar mais uma temporada a série o
relatório a gente vai fazer de madrugada
né investir dinheiro guardar dinheiro ou
comprar essa bolsa e sapato esse celular
novo que está aqui na minha frente
pedindo para ser comprado
mas sua intenção à dieta às promoções
profissionais a viagem
todas essas intenções que você pensa
sobre elas programa projeta a se
instalar na sua cama tentar só não
avançando que vem eu queria fazer uma
pós graduação e não sei aonde queria
viajar queria mas na hora h de pegar o
dinheiro e guardar
mas tem alguma força que não ajuda
alguma força que atrapalha
e aí está o ponto fundamental do que eu
quero conversar com vocês hoje
por que será que a gente tem dentro de
nós
alguém que parece que o tempo inteiro
jogando contra a gente
qual dos dois fenômenos mentais é mais
importante para nós aquele que projeta a
dieta na segunda feira aquele que
projeta a viagem no ano que vem ou
aquele que chica mão que come ou aquele
que passa o cartão de crédito na hora de
fazer a compra
qual desses dois sistemas é mais seu
amigo
qual dessas duas porções de você do seu
comportamento estão mais antenados com
as suas necessidades
em geral as pessoas vão dizer assim é
importante fazer é a dieta é economizar
dinheiro sabe que nome que a gente dá
pra isso a gente chama isso de livre
arbítrio e livre arbítrio apesar de a
gente imaginar que seja uma coisa assim
de liberdade que seja uma coisa boa
ela sempre nos é vendida como ônibus
parece bônus mas na hora que você vai
ver mesmo o teu livre arbítrio o que faz
você poder pagar a conta
é porque você tem livre arbítrio que
você pode ser penalizado pelos seus
erros
uma pessoa inimputável por diferentes
razões por ter alguma deficiência por
ter alguma dificuldade em tomar decisões
acertadas pode ser uma doença mental
pode ser por uma questão qualquer de
nascimento ela é e limpo tável porque
não se atribui a ela o valor do livre
arbítrio
quem tem livre arbítrio pode se sentir
vai descido disso mas na verdade isso é
um baita de um problema e só 11 anos
algo pelo qual a gente paga muitas vezes
então se de um lado o conceito de livre
arbítrio é um conceito que nos atribui
responsabilidade
na outra ponta está o conceito de
liberdade
ai fala a palavra tem uma sensação zinha
não é ali fia
eu sou livre então me diga uma coisa
diante da mesa de brigadeiros e você
dieta não esqueça que sempre dá aquela
falha na memória daquele momento em
diante na mesa de brigadeiros o que é
ter livre arbítrio e o que é ser livre
livre arbítrio é você naquele momento
olhava mesmo de brigadeiro disse assim
seu começo o brigadeiro eu vou sair da
minha dieta
vou fugir do meu propósito e pagarei a
conta por isso a liberdade é quer saber
mereço só um só hoje a semana toda sem
comer brigadeiros
tem gente que é um pouco mais dramático
ela passa o dia sem comer brigadeiro da
noite ela merece
mas se o exercício da liberdade será que
o livre arbítrio e liberdade são
realmente coisas tão antagônicas assim
quando a gente pensa neles parece estão
falando a mesma coisa
e tem gente que usa como sinônimo eu
tenho liberdade eu sou livre para tomar
decisões eu tenho livre arbítrio
o livre arbítrio ele vem como recompensa
pela última das funções que nós
desenvolvemos nosso cérebro que a função
consciente
se você pegar um animal eu tenho uma
gatinha em casa que tem dá um ótimo
exemplo disso pra gente
ela sabe que eu vou sair de casa ela
sabe porquê porque tem informações no
meio que dizem ela que eu vou sair em
geral é uma bolsa que o pega um sapato
que o ponham uma movimentação é
provavelmente está agitada e isso lá
percebe pela emocionalidade dela quer
dizer todas as vezes que eu tenho esse
comportamento geralmente eu saio de casa
e ela sabe que toda vez que eu saio eu
dou um bifinho pra ela
então ela tem um comportamento que não
tem que tirar isso dela de quando ela
percebe
que eu vou sair de casa ela corre para
um lugar onde eu dou bife brown e
daniela fica enquanto ela não tiver
plena convicção de que eu desistir de
sair de casa e isso pode demorar horas
ela permanece naquele lugar depois que
eu sentei no sofá atirou o sapato
larguei a bolsa desistir de sair ainda
demora um tempo para ela desistir de
ganhar o briefing às vezes ela percebe
alguma coisa que dá impressão para ela
de que eu vou sair e ela admite que eu
vou sair e corre para lá
isso é um comportamento mobilizado pela
capacidade que os animais têm que nós
também temos de perceber no ambiente
o que nós precisamos fazer para nos
darmos bem na hora que você chega na
beira da mesa de doces na hora que você
vai chegando na sua casa perto do
controle remoto hoje você pode ligar a
sua série predileta esse sistema disse
pra você assim hora do bichinho anual do
fim hora do brigadeiro hora da série mas
é exatamente a mesma coisa que há
gatinha fez
é o mesmo sistema ele tem uma força em
nós que ele praticamente subtrai
sequestra todo o nosso comportamento
a coisa mais difícil do mundo é neste
momento você usar a outra parte do
sistema
aquela do tal do livre arbítrio que o
gatinho não tem e arbítrio
ela não é capaz de julgar quais são as
causas e conseqüências dos atos que ela
tem ela não é capaz de perceber que ela
está perdendo tempo esperando eu saísse
eu já desisti de sair ela podia talvez
ela arruma bifinho de outra forma
ela dá um outro jeito de um outro
comportamento que dê a ela bifinhos não
ela tem um estreitamento de repertório
que faz com que ela sempre faça a mesma
coisa para obter o sempre o mesmo
resultado
obviamente que nós por conta da nossa
consciência e total do livre arbítrio
podemos fazer outras escolhas
eu tenho a chance de falar não para o
brigadeiro
mas eu não uso
pouquíssimos de nós conseguem
efetivamente usar quando a força
emocional quando a oportunidade vem
forte como é o caso por exemplo dos
pinhos para a minha gatinha é muito
importante para ela que é a única chance
que ela tem de se alimentar de coisas
super gostosa o resto do tempo aquela
razão odiosa
é mais ou menos o que a gente faz com a
gente também
a gente vive o tempo inteiro trabalhando
se arrastando cumprindo protocolos e aí
o brigadeiro e a série se torna um
bifinho da vida da gente ea gente
estreita o nosso comportamento por causa
disso
e aí aquela hora eu só consigo fazer
daquele jeito
eu aqui com a segunda feira lá eu
consigo fazer dieta na segunda feira mas
à medida que eu vou me aproximando dela
à força de não fazer a força de me
deixar levar por aquilo que
emocionalmente é relevante para mim
aumenta ea minha capacidade de controle
e de praticar o tal do livre arbítrio
que me faz ter as atitudes corretas
diminui
portanto passa o dia todo nós passamos
todos os nossos dias
neste balanço entre o que é
emocionalmente relevante que nós
gostaríamos muito de te e tudo aquilo
que a gente precisa fazer esses dois
sistemas vivem em conflito
por essa razão nós temos cada vez mais
vivenciado em nossa sociedade as
questões relativas à saúde mental
é por isso que as pessoas de crime
é por isso que as pessoas vivenciem
rosas e quanto mais emoções e prazeres
eu consigo te quanto mais próximo de mim
estão essas potências de comer ou de
fazer onde ter coisas que me interessam
que são emocionalmente relevante para
mim - força eu tenho pra tomar as
decisões que eu considero corretas
adequadas
o futuro bom dilema posto
se vocês concordam que nós temos esses
dois lados e que isso é muito forte em
todos nós
eu sigo com uma proposta a proposta de
harmonia entre esses dois lados
até os 20 anos de idade nós
desenvolvemos nosso cérebro de forma
setorial cada parte cuidando de um
aspecto da nota o nosso comportamento em
adolescentes o conflito entre o que eu
tenho que fazer o que eu quero fazer
chega a níveis assustadores e por essa
razão nós estamos cada vez mais
observando as questões de saúde mental
nos adolescentes
quanto mais oportunidades eles têm de
fazer coisas incríveis - força eles têm
para fazer aquilo que eles precisam
fazer isso também é verdade que os
adultos mas os adultos ganham uma
oportunidade de mudar essa história
e qual é essa oportunidade é transformar
as intenções declaradas e obrigatórias
que eu tenho que são as coisas que eu
defendo que eu preciso fazer a dieta o
relatório a ginástica a a boa ação o
trabalho voluntário todas as coisas que
eu considero que são importantes para
fazer que são as minhas intenções
declaradas precisam ser harmonizados com
as com a minha emocionalidade eu preciso
colocar elementos emocionais relevantes
que têm 'parem essas intenções
declaradas e a partir deste processo
construir o que eu chamo de intenções
genuínas temperar com emoções relevantes
aquilo que é importante para mim
dos 20 aos 30 anos o nosso cérebro se
desenvolve fazendo conexões entre áreas
diferentes
não obrigatoriamente eu posso morrer sem
fazer essas conexões porque o cérebro
ele não tem um desenvolvimento contínuo
que é dependente dos seus aniversários
o desenvolvimento cerebral está a atirar
também associado às experiências que
você tem e de que forma você dá ênfase
para essas experiências então momento em
que você consegue construir um
comportamento harmônico que tem perry
com emoções
aquilo que você considera que deve fazer
as suas intenções declaradas
você constrói uma intenção genuína em
que a harmonia entre esses dois
elementos e isso se configura no seu
cérebro como uma nova conexão entre
áreas diferentes do seu sábio justamente
o sistema emocional que minha gatinha
tem qualquer outro animal tem que nós
temos também que dar relevância as
coisas que a gente vive é o sistema
consciente que diz o que a gente deve
fazer para temperar isso a trazer emoção
pra esse sistema consciente
a melhor coisa é conscientemente
procurar as emoções que validam suas
intenções
então se você vou dar um exemplo da
dieta que é um exemplo é comum em muita
gente
se você tem um dilema em fazer dieta
comece a construir um cenário de emoções
que validem cada uma das suas atitudes
quando você está fazendo direto por
exemplo ao invés de ficar toda hora
olhando para a balança para ver quanto
peso você perdeu
você pode ir experimentando roupas que
você não cabia é mais fácil uma roupa
entrar do que a balança diminuir
só que se quer ficar brigando com a
balança e esquece de ver outros recursos
para que você vá lide emocionalmente que
você está fazendo
fez o relatório terminou relatório
comemore porque o seu mais seu sistema
emocional conhece a celebração
aí você não precisa mais ficar vivendo
em antíteses porque livre arbítrio é
responsabilidade e liberdade é prazer
então melhor forma de você coordenar o
seu comportamento para que você não viva
ansioso deprimido lamentando os recursos
ea vida que você tem é harmonizar a sua
liberdade
com o seu livre arbítrio construir uma
vida de vocês harmonizando esses dois
lados porque desta forma você com
certeza vai encontrar uma vida mais
plena que vale a pena ser vivida e não
apenas uma vida
thanks god is freeday mais importante é
que a gente construa uma vida onde as
segundas feiras também devem ser
celebrados
[Aplausos]
[Música]